[MUSIC]
My name is Kirsten Moss and
I'm the Dean of Admissions and
Financial Aid at Stanford.
And really looking forward to our session,
our regional session on New York today.
Thank you for coming.
I'm a little sad because every summer I
get a chance to come out to New York and
meet some of our prospects out there.
And with the global pandemic,
that's obviously not possible today.
When we really have thought about how
do we bring Stanford to you in a still
personal way, but do it online.
So what we would have done last year is
an information session on the admissions
officer like myself would tell you about
the program what's distinctive and
really talk about how to put your best
foot forward in the application process.
And then the second thing we would do
is hear from a panel of students and
alumni who have experienced the GSB.
And what we've seen from our research from
our surveys is that's really the most
important thing for
most of our prospects to see themselves
at the school understand that experience.
So today, we're really going to
focus on that for 45 minutes.
We know in Zoom, we don't want to keep
you on the screen for an hour and a half.
So we're just going to do this part.
We're going to do panelist
introductions first, I'll do that.
And then after that,
we're going to have a moderated Q&A.
So I'll start off with a couple questions,
but it's really going to be up to you to
submit your questions via the chat box,
the Q&A box.
So I know what's on your mind and
we can make sure you get the most
out of the session as possible.
And just a reminder that this is
really the panel part of the session.
So if you're interested after spending
some time with us and want to learn more,
I highly encourage you to come to one
of a virtual information session so
you can learn more about
the admissions process and
what you can do to put your best
foot forward in your application.
Now one more tip I think is we're
starting to have in the session is,
as you meet our panelists, they all
come from very different backgrounds.
One thing you can do as a prospect and
thinking about your application
process is really we ask you
questions like what matters most and
why in your essays or
what do you want to get out of your MBA?.
Why Stanford?.
As you listen to students stories,
I'm sure that will help you begin
reflecting on what you're interested in
accomplishing.
So I hope you keep that in the back of
your mind as you hear from our panelists.
Now, I'm going to ask,
we have five panelists today and
we purposely selected them
from the region of New York.
So they've all gone to school, the West
Coast and moved back to the East Coast.
But we've made sure that they're coming
from a variety of industries and
healthcare, gaming, consulting,
tech, but also different functions.
So we have a chief of staff and
product marketing, general manager.
And I'm going to start off with asking
Jack to introduce themselves as class.
And the first question I'd love you to
answer each of the panelists is tell
me about an academic experience that
was meaningful to you at Stanford.
>> Awesome thanks, Kirsten.
So Jack Armstrong originally from the UK.
Before business school, I was
an operational restructuring consultant.
So I specialized in turnaround and
transformation projects
all across the world.
After Business School, I'm going to
work in private equity operations.
So I'm going to be Chief of Staff for
a portfolio company on the East Coast just
outside of New York, working on behalf
of the fund with the healthcare pharma
company to hopefully drive some
improvements over the next few years.
So it's my favorite academic experience.
I think MGE for me as a whole is my
favorite class of business school.
MGE stands for
managing growing enterprises.
And it's really taking a lot of what we
learn about leadership and management and
applying in to real world situations.
So, we have the protagonist of a case in
the class who worked through the case.
The professor's really drill in and dig in
and make us roleplay various scenarios.
And then we get to hear what
actually happened as an outcome.
And so for me, it was fantastic experience
because it took all of the learning that
we've done, and
applied it in practice in the classroom.
And we had a chance to speak
to some of the amazing guests.
>> Awesome, fantastic.
And I'm going to leave this panelist
description up here while they speak about
their back of the first question and
their names and
then we'll take it off so
you can see their faces.
So Michelle, let us know
>> Everyone I'm Michelle Baumgartner,
I'm calling from the the woods
of Northern Wisconsin.
So if I break up, bear with me but
I am originally from Toronto in Canada.
So I grew up there, but I went to
college at the University of Minnesota.
I worked for Accenture in strategy
consulting before the GSB.
I did an internship at We Work
in New York last summer.
And then I'm going to be starting in
a couple weeks as a product marketing
manager at Unity Technologies.
So it's a gaming startup in San Francisco.
And then my favorite- Jack almost
stole mine but I have a backup.
Mine, I have to say so, I was a business
undergrad and I was in some ways
skeptical that I was going to be
repeating a lot of the same classes, but
I think one thing I fell in love with and
I was pleasantly surprised to find
out a business school was there
are these sort of more interpersonal and
interpersonal classes that
I've really enjoyed and
will be I'm sure talking more about them,
but one of them was touchy feely.
I also took art of self coaching and
lives of consequences.
And so I think those types of classes,
the more soft skill classes are really
the highlight of my experience.
>> Eric, let's move to you.
>> Sure.
Hi, everyone.
So I think I was born and
raised in New York City, so
shout out to all the New York City
folks on the line.
And I joke that I grew up as the son of
an abstract painter and a lung doctor.
So I was introduced from the beginning.
And the way that showed up for
me professionally is just post GSP.
I worked at McKinsey before joining
Capsule as director of product.
Before that,
I was on Design Thinking consulting, so
a lot of deep user research and
creating new products and services.
And I would say one of the standout
academic experiences to
me was in Rob Siegel's on
industrialist dilemma class.
Where you have some of the titans of
industry come in and talk about how they
view innovation disruption and
what's happening in their industry.
And then you also have some of
the disruptors who were coming in.
So hearing for example, from
an autonomous vehicle's CEO right after
hearing from Ford CEO about the future
of mobility, I think create a really
rich cross functional perspective
that I loved and gained a lot from.
>> Aditi, why don't you start.
>> Sure Hi, I'm Aditi Banga,
I'm graduated from the GSB
in the class of 2015.
So it's been five years
which is a little crazy.
[LAUGH] I can't believe how
quickly the time has gone.
Before the GSB, I started out
working in management consulting.
I was at the Monitor Group
which is now owned by Deloitte.
And then I spent two years working in
mobile gaming as a product manager,
actually for a startup that was started
by members of the class of GSB 2010.
And then after that,
after the GSP I was initially
based out in the area working for
Apple for the Movies and
TV division and then my husband and
I are both from New York originally.
So, a couple of years ago
we relocated back here.
I am now at Instagram working
on our media partnerships team,
focusing specifically on shopping.
So working with just
a number of brands and
media partners on commerce related
activities on the platform.
My favorite class of the GSB, let's see,
so, I actually, I also really loved MGE.
But another one that I was a big fan of,
is, this class called Leadership and
Entertainment, which is typically
a second year elective,
but you can also take it as a first year.
And it's just an incredible speaker
series, where every session you
have numbers of different parts of
the entertainment industry visit, and
talk about what it's like
to work in the industry.
And so,
really get that real world perspective.
>> Great, thank you.
And Will, how about you?
>> Hi, Rao, how's it going?
I graduated from GSB last year, so
I've been out for about a year now.
Before that I had worked at Bain and
Company in Chicago, and
before that had gone to Notre Dame.
For me, Eric actually stole mine,
I love the industrialist dilemma as well.
But, probably, my second favorite class,
as I also was doing my Masters in
Ed at the time, was a class called
Leading your Schools, which was taught
by a practitioner who runs the largest
charter network in Los Angeles.
So he'd fly up from Los Angeles
once a week to teach our class.
And he brought in ten speakers over
the course of the year, who had tried, and
in most cases had failed, to turn
around large US public school systems.
And I thought that was
fascinating because it was so
topical to a lot of the big
education debates we were having.
Many of them had a business background,
and also many of them had actually failed.
And so you've got to hear from people who,
I think we saw had succeeded, but
others who had not succeeded and
talk about what the difference
is driving that might have been.
>> All right, thanks, cool.
Well, thank all of you for
the introductions.
And I'm now going to the chat right now.
And one of the first questions,
which is great since we're doing the New
York Region, is, Caroline wanted to know,
could you talk about the GSB
network in New York City?
And I've heard this a lot, as I'm out
on the road that students realize,
many of our alumni love the Bay Area and
stay, so
how was it to both come back, and
what's the community like there now?
And maybe Aditi,
could could speak to that, and
then Eric, because you guys
have been out the longest.
>> All right, it's great actually,
so it's funny.
I am guessing in absolute numbers,
it's smaller than the Bay Area,
but kind of, maybe it's because
it is a smaller community.
I actually find that I
spent a lot more time with
the GSB community here in New York.
In the Bay Area,
I think the bulk of my GSB time was spent
with my close friends from my own class.
But less so with members of other classes,
or are partaking in,
some of them were optional activities
that you can do after you graduate.
So things like the women's Sacco
which is an ability to kind of form
a network of women across different
GSB graduating years, and
you come together once in a month.
And Just talk about both professional and
personal-
>> Experience.
>> Topics and that's something
that I'm participating in here.
So, in some ways I found that
I've tapped into more of the GSB
resources based out in New York.
And I think there's also
something exciting about,
you meet somebody else from
the GSB here in New York, and
you kind of feel this
immediate kindred spirit.
And it feels a little bit more special
because, there might be fewer of you.
So I found that, it's been a fun
way to bond with people as well.
>> Awesome.
How about you, Eric?
>> I think that was extremely well said,
I echo and agree with everything.
And the only piece I'll add on,
is, because
people who are self selecting to go to New
York, it's a slightly more active choice.
I think it tends to have that extra
special sense of community because of it,
which I, Yeah,
I agree with everything that was said.
>> Eric,
how did you think about recruiting,
trying to get back out to New York when
your second year was that challenging or?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
I personally ended up starting
with McKenzie in California, and
then transitioning back to New York.
And I think there are a lot of people who
make the choice to stay for a year or
two or three in the Bay Area,
and then either stay forever or
later move back, because, there is kind of
this special moment that can happen just
after graduating,
to be with a large portion of the class.
When it came to coming back to New York,
it really helped to be able to
reach out to the alumni network,
genuinely it was extremely helpful.
And honestly, during school,
I know a lot of people, well, I know
some people who it took an extra effort
to recruit back and forth with New York.
But I think the folks who determined
that was what they wanted to do,
all achieved it.
>> Awesome, that's great.
One of the questions that have come in,
and it's about leadership from Andrew,
which leadership experience at the GSB
was most transformative for you, and how?
Everyone mention our favorite classes,
but would love to learn more specifically
about how it transformed these
leadership capabilities.
So, maybe we'll start with Michelle and
Jack, you guys are recent,
it's top of mind,
I'm sure some of these things for you.
>> Yeah, I'm kind of caught between,
trying two experiences.
But I think, what came to mind first was,
so, I was in this class called startup
garage, which was a pretty popular class,
it's application based.
So, I think, so
I've always had this interest.
I've only really worked before the GSB
at really big companies, with Accenture,
very kind of the classic
fortune 500 companies.
And so I had this interest in working for
a smaller company during my internship
there and then ultimately,
joining a small startup after the GSB.
So, I think it was just really helpful for
me to get this taste of,
what is it like to basically
start with nothing but an idea.
With four people and
be together in a room,
we probably worked about 20
hours a week plus on this idea.
And with classmates that
you think are your friends,
and you really don't know someone
until you start working with them.
And so not that we had,
there was obviously conflict, but
there was also just like wonderful
moments of, wow, you're great
at specializing this and you specialize
this, but I want to learn about this.
So, I think I learned a lot about
just working with people and
just leadership in general, and if you
have a different direction on this idea,
how do you sort of present and get the
other three people to come along with it.
So, I think that was definitely
a highlight from me.
>> What was the product
just out of curiosity,
for those who don't know
how start apprentice?
>> So, so, we started with an idea.
So, our idea was basically as I mentioned,
we worked last summer.
I also have an art major, so Our idea was
basically there's this crazy stat that
is only 5% of films that are produced
actually make it to theaters.
Now, obviously different,
nothing's in theaters right now, but so
there's basically all this content that's
out there that basically doesn't find
distribution and might go direct to
Netflix or direct to another platform.
And so, we were basically interested in
is there a way to basically
leverage underutilized spaces.
So, say like a coffee shop that closes
down at 7PM, could we rent it until nine?
Bring a portable projector, and
basically stream a movie for
a budding film director.
And so, we're kind of interested in this
kind of Airbnb for small format cinema.
>> That's cool.
>> We called ourself Minima, actually
the company is sort of pivoted and
I'm no longer involved which
I can expand on later.
But yeah, it was a really just
fascinating experience with kind of
the intersection of business in
which is where I'm interested in.
>> Awesome, thank you.
How about you Jack?
How did your leadership
transform at the GSB?
>> Yeah, great question.
I think, for me,
the course that was most impactful was
touchy feely or interpersonal dynamics.
I think the reason for
that is because the GSB teaches you
many leadership models but doesn't tell
you there is a right way because it's
all individual to you as a leader.
So I think, leading to that then,
interpersonal dynamics for
me was the most impactful because
it helped me understand myself and
the impact that I have on people out
of all the courses at the GSB the most.
Which I can then transition to,
well, how do I then show up?
And what does that mean in
terms of my leadership style?
This was a very interesting
class as a Brit,
the thought of been sat
in a room with 11 people.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But no real agenda, actually.
>> So what we think about each other,
at least Gary, is we have a way in the UK
of saying everything but what we think.
So for me, it's just fascinating to really
spend time with a group of peers and
learn about the impact that you have on
them and how other people impact you.
And take those learnings and
then apply it to well,
how does that mean that I show
up as a person and as a leader?
>> Is there an example?
I'm not going to put you on the spot.
You don't have to give us,
sometimes it's hard to understand
what the concrete learning is.
And I think that wasn't a question of
something you learned and touchy feely.
>> Yeah, so I think one of
the things I learned was that,
I'll give you a really basic example.
I use humor a lot to defuse situations.
And sometimes that works and
sometimes it doesn't.
And so, what was really great for
me was understanding when
taking the heat out of a situation or
using humor to build the group is useful.
And actually,
when it's [INAUDIBLE] tractor.
And so, that was just one example of
hundreds of things that I learned, but
just getting enough reps to understand,
okay, this is a really useful skill.
But I have to choose when to
use it at the right time.
>> I love that.
So, it sounds like managing conflict
productively, and what are the tools,
that's great.
Thank you.
I'm going to go to the next question.
So, Diego's asking from New Jersey,
can you spend a little time
telling us about why you decided
to go to business school, so
some have pivoted in industries and
others haven't.
And wanted a little insight into that.
And Will, maybe we'll start with you,
because you didn't pivot industries and
decide to go to business school.
Maybe you can share that.
Yeah, I mean, for me,
I think there were kind of three things
that led me to take
the business school experience.
One was I wanted the kind of safe
opportunity to test out other things.
Even though I knew I was going back
to Bain, business school was kind of
an awesome way for me to think about
what I wanted to do long term.
So, I did my Master's in
education at the same time.
And I got the chance to work with a lot
of different nonprofits while I was in
the school and kind of understand where I
want to fit into that space down the road.
And then the second thing for
me was to build a network outside of
just my college peers and my company.
And in particular, build a network that
was going to be international, and
that has been really amazing.
We can talk a little bit about it later,
but I think that the GSP network is
more powerful than I could ever
even have possibly imagined.
I remember like two weeks into school,
someone posted on our
Slack channel that one of her friends
had gotten into trouble in South Sudan.
And she was like,
do you know anyone we can call?
And within like five minutes, like three
or four people had given her the names of
like diplomats or ambassadors or
people in South Sudan.
And I was like, well, if the GSP can
give us contacts in South Sudan, there's
probably nowhere in the world we're not
going to have kind of people at our back.
And then for
me finally, I was just really kind of
burnt out after three years of work.
I was tired,
I wanted the chance to kind of refresh.
And what I found was that Stanford got me
excited again, about a lot of the things
that I was working on, helped me to
step back, think about my career.
Is not like a of couple years
is a hard work, but really,
it's kind of a 40 year journey and all
the interesting places that could take me.
So, those were the reasons
that I ended up, and
I think the GSB kind of knocked it out
of the park in all of those dimensions.
>> Awesome, and
how does it feel to be back at Bain now?
How are you different in the role?
So, that's why you went.
If you look back-
>> Yeah.
>> What was the value for you?
>> One day, I think that I was
talking to a few people about this,
who had done consulting and then got back
to very similar roles in consulting, and
we all felt way better at our jobs.
And that actually, in some ways,
was not something that we were expecting.
There were a lot of things we
are expecting out of this school,
I actually wasn't expecting to
feel that much better because so
much of what you learn
is learned on the job.
But I think it really helped with
maturity, with being able to step back.
And during the school you
have the chance to examine so
many cases, to meet with so
many important speakers
that it almost feels like it
gave me like greater gravitas.
And a greater ability to bring in
experiences that I had seen at the GSB.
And I've actually used a lot of what
I learned in classes, frameworks or
ways of thinking or
case studies and that has surprised me,
been kind of a nice and pleasant surprise.
>> Awesome.
How about Michelle?
I didn't give you a heads up early.
How are you thinking about pivoting
from into gaming and product marketing?
>> Yeah, totally.
So, I mentioned I was at Accenture for
three years.
But my background is somewhat unique.
I was told, at least at my university,
I was the only one that has ever
majored in finance and fine arts.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, my majors,
just the story behind that is I'm
passionate about both things.
I love business, I think like
business is kind of everything.
But then, I also love, I'm a film junkie,
I love going to Sundance,
I actually lived in Park City for
four years.
And so, I knew I always had
this interest in entertainment.
I did work with a few media entertainment
clients when I was at Accenture,
and I really liked that, it was like
the most hip clients I kind of had.
But I knew I wanted to do something
smaller and something more creative.
I can't say I felt super creative and
my role was really leveraging,
kind of playing to that strength.
And so, I came back to business school.
I was interested in one kind of
pivoting industries, but also being
more in an operating role, in a product
role approach to business and operations.
And so, I ended up sort of, for
the summer Trying something out
at WeWork in an operating role and
actually really liked that type of role.
But I wasn't quite in
the industry that I wanted and
so was able to find something at
a small gaming startup for full time.
And so, I think it was a result of
lots of networking with alumni,
just speaking with them.
I mentioned the startup garage
experience really impacting kind of my
interest in entertainment.
And specifically gaming and so that was
sort of my rational part coming back and
hopefully it goes well when I
start in a couple of weeks.
>> Awesome.
And the next question was
about the culture and
Aditi I'm going to to ask this one to you.
Alyssa is asking what makes
a GSB culture unique and
what sets it apart from
other MBA programs?
So I don't expect you to speak about other
programs that I as a dean of admissions,
I keep calling it magic.
And that's pretty high
level how you describe it,
so what tactically is it like
to be part of the culture?
>> My gosh.
I mean, it is magical,
it's hard to sometimes
sum it up into words but
I think what really stands out to me is
how supportive of a program it is.
I think I was always
interested in getting my MBA.
I, over the course of like the first
few years that I was working,
got a better understanding of what
I hoped to get out of the program.
Many, many reasons for being kind of
similar to Will in terms of, really,
it's a safe space to experiment and learn.
I used to look at the other people
who were [INAUDIBLE] who had MBAs and
really admired their skills in
terms of how to manage teams or
work with teams, their presence,
their ability to present well.
But I think what I just didn't
expect going into it was how
I'd come out of it with
the closest friends of my life,
truly, truly like my lifelong friends.
I got married a couple years ago, and
most of my bridal party was from the GSB.
And I didn't expect that
going into business school.
I kind of thought I'd found my closest
friends in college and everything but
I think there's just something different.
And maybe part of it's in some ways a very
intense two years right, it's busy.
Between classes and extracurriculars and
the social component, it's quite busy.
And then the kinds of classes you're
taking, to go through experiences like
interpersonal dynamics, they're not
easy courses or startup garage where
you're really learning how to kind of
work with each other in a different way.
I think what I just didn't expect was how
helpful and supportive everyone would be.
You ask somebody for
guidance or for advice or
you want to talk to them about what it was
like to work in this industry or that or
you don't know how to do
your operations homework or
your accounting homework and
everyone will drop everything to help you.
And I think that's pretty special.
And I can't speak to whether that sets it
apart necessarily from other programs, but
it I guess it went beyond my expectations.
>> Is there someone else
who wants to jump in?
Any of the other panelists who
feels strongly about the culture?
All right, Jack.
>> I can quickly jump in.
So the community feel is amazing,
as was just described, but
one small example would be I'd spoken
to a friend and said I'm thinking
of recruiting for these kind of
roles in passing in the coffee shop.
And then two days later I'm walking
through campus through town square and
he stops me and he says, well just so
you know, these two companies
are on campus in the next two days.
I spoke to them, I gave them your name,
let me know if you need any help.
Let me know if you want to chat
through anything and went on his way.
I'd forgotten I even told him the type
of thing that I was interested in.
And he'd gone out of his way
then to think about who he knew,
think about who he could put me in touch
with, coached me through the process.
And that's not unusual.
For homework, for people, for
events, for trips, for any class,
I think people are always thinking
about their classmates, their friends,
how they can help and support and
how they can be there.
I think that's just one example in
a professional context of how it happened,
but it happens in a personal
context all the time.
>> That's awesome.
I want to make sure we cover
the global experience.
So Eric, maybe you could, you're nodding,
I see your head, do you want to share?
We have a global experience requirement.
There are many ways that you
can fulfill that as a student,
but perhaps talk to what you did?
>> Yeah, happy to.
So I chose to do a couple of
experiences both formal and informal.
Informal as many classmates were from
various countries wanted to create
experiences for people to come and
walk a little bit in their shoes and those
were some of my favorite experiences.
Two foreign ones, I did the step
program which was an exchange
program with Sang Mai University in China.
I also did a global study trip,
to Mexico and
the Mexico trip,
I had been to Mexico briefly before.
But it was a experience that I
could not have done anywhere else.
And I think a few things
that stood out about it.
One was the leaders were extremely
thoughtful and extremely vulnerable in
how they shared their own personal stories
and how that intersected with the country.
And so I could see it not only
from my lens with classmates, but
also from the way they
were viewing things.
So for example, one of the students
had attended Harvard and
I think he had had a scholarship
there earlier on in his life.
And there was a number, it became actually
a national controversy at the time,
where people were talking about like hey
why are we helping this person whose
family had come into the US illegally
versus someone who was born in the US?
And so hearing him talk about that
story and then together as a group
crossing the border in Tijuana gave
it a really different experience.
And so
I think like the global experiences,
I think helped us really to go to a much
deeper level in understanding each other.
And then they were also extremely fun and
we went to like just great places we
wouldn't have been to otherwise and
the chance to spend so
much time with each other.
Going through these once
in a lifetime experiences,
I think was one of the major ways that
I made some of my closest friends.
>> Awesome.
I'm looking at the time and I'd like all
of you to give me a wrap up comment.
And I think the one of the questions that
came in is if you had any words of advice,
so if someone's admitted to the GSB, and
you're looking back, what advice would
you give them about coming to the school?
So how about I'll start with you Will.
>> Yeah, sure thing.
Well, so first of all,
you should definitely come.
I know some people get
into business school and
they're like, like should I do it?
It's definitely worth it.
And there was not a single
person I knew in my class who
didn't think it was
worth it by like a mile.
The one other thing I'd say is, it makes
a lot of sense to Like plan in advance,
because it is really like
an overwhelming experience.
There's so much going on.
There's so
many interesting people to meet,
that I think it's really helpful to have
a sense of what you want to get out of it.
And it's really okay if what you want to
get out of it is, trying something or
testing something that turns out to
not be at all what you want to do.
There's always you know, that's
actually a really helpful learning, but
I think it's worth planning in advance.
And then the other thing I think is just
like throwing yourself in and not letting
it slip by, I mean when I look back at
the GSB I have very few regrets but
the only things I regret are like if
anything, not trying to do more or
not making more time to
do all of those things.
It's really such a unique to your
experience surrounded by incredible people
with unlimited resources and
opportunities at your disposal.
So I think you want to
make the most of that
>> Hey,
Dita How about you give us a wrap
on this question too please.
Some advice.
>> Sure yeah.
So I think I would say that let's see,
it's going to say kind
of what Bill was saying.
But I mean, I think I'm being really
open to new experiences, I mean,
I think people have different
comfort levels of how much
they want to trying new things versus
not versus kind of sticking with like,
the types of classes that
they know they'll do well in.
Or like the types of friends that they
used to have prior to business school.
I just think that it's such an opportunity
to push yourself outside of your
comfort zone, take that class that you
don't have a background in at all, or
spend time with people who just aren't
like the rest of your friends so far.
There's never going to really be
another opportunity to do that, and
it might surprise you in terms
of what you find that you like.
>> I'm looking at the time anybody else
want to jump in Eric, Michelle or Jack?
What's some advice?
Okay.
>> Yeah, it's it's sort of similar but,
yeah, I completely agree
with the comments about being open to
a bunch of different types of experience.
But if there's one thing that
can summarize the last two
years it is incredibly busy.
And I think just having the ability
to focus, and have maybe a few
things that you really know you want to
prioritize and get involved in.
I think, just an example in the fall of,
second year,
you're going to see a lot of your
classmates recruiting for consulting.
And for a while, I was like, should I
recruit for another consulting firm, but
I was like, no, no, I came here to do and
I want to stay true to that.
And so
I think kind of being your own person and
focusing, I took art
classes across the street,
even though no one else was sort of
doing that, just the ability to focus.
And, yeah, like I said, be your own person
I think is some good advice I give.
>> That's awesome.
Jackie, were nodding your head, did you
want to say one last thing as well?
>> Yeah,
just those ruthless priorities and
make sure you have it have a good
system for holding yourself to account.
I remember you know, week one student life
telling me about, proactively calendaring.
I can remember being Saturday going,
I'm a grown up, I can manage my calendar.
I used to 10 businesses around.
And then two days later,
I'm like, quadruple booked
four times in the same day.
And I felt like a drink from a firehose,
so, have these disparities,
find somebody outside of
the GSB to hold you to account.
And somebody that you can come back to and
say,
okay do I really need this brown bag lunch
or am I just going for the sandwich?
>> That's great.
Finally, Eric,
why don't you help us close?
>> Yeah.
So I'll see it's builds on what
a number of others have said.
I said the main thing is slowly smooth and
smooth is fast.
When you first come, there can be
an incredible rush to do everything,
to try everything, to meet everyone.
And I personally think that I
would have gone farther and
gotten even more out of it.
If I take the time to get to know
each person a little bit more.
If I take in the time to think of it
not as a two year sprint, actually,
like two years a meaningful
chunk of life and
there's a lot that you can get
done there if you set yourself up.
Where it's a way that you could continue,
if it were the rest of your life,
and so I think if you find a way, even if
it's hard to prioritize, to slow down and
spend that extra 30 minutes with
someone versus 20 short coffee chats,
or you spend that extra time on
that case to go deeper on it.
That you may find that you'll learn more
quickly what it is that you want to do,
and that ultimately leads you to knowing
more people who will stay close to
your heart.
So I encourage you to go slow to go fast.
>> That's great.
I think that's a wonderful place to end.
I'm going to share just
a couple more slides but
want to thank Jack,
Michelle, Will, DT, Eric.
Thank you so much for being here.
So Stanford here's a quick picture of
our courtyard we call it town square and
the GSB buildings.
And when this campus was
built just eight years ago,
the cornerstone actually says, dedicated
to the things that haven't happened yet
and the people who
are about to dream them up.
And I think that really captures
the essence of Stanford.
We hope if you've come today that you
see yourself as a big dreamer, and
you'll be interested in learning more.
Stanford is really built for
people like you.
And if you want to learn more,
you got a chance to hear from
some of our wonderful alumni.
But as I said earlier, feel free to book
an information session if you really
want to think about admissions,
and what we're looking for.
There's also industry panels.
For instance, if you are looking for
a career in finance come hear from a whole
panel of finance, alumni and students.
And then we have added in the last 18
months, some small group chats which is
really about 10 prospects with the either
an admissions officer or students.
So it's a more intimate environment where
you can get your individual questions
answered.
Please, if I didn't get there many
questions in the chat if I didn't get to
yours, you can also email us on the web.
We appreciate that.
And just in closing, if you do come
to Stanford, we believe that it
will really open your horizons, your self
narrative of what you can accomplish.
We think will teach you to think boldly,
think innovatively, it'll help
you develop your leadership capabilities
so others will want to follow you.
And finally it will help you
to find the path not just for
these next two years but
for the next 40 years.
So you can see our mission and we really
try to live it at Stanford each and
every day.
So thank you so much for
joining us and have a good one.
[MUSIC]